[Música]
meu nome é grande dá eu sou jornalista
eu sou apresentadora de tv repórter há
mais de 25 anos embora não pareça mais
gosta de fazer na vida
tem duas coisas que mais gosto de fazer
na vida é contar a história dessas
pessoas pra outras pessoas
isso me deixa extremamente satisfeita é
eu lembro que um ótimo primeiro chef
joão paulo ii rua termina a dor de
cabeça é rapidinho e é a pura verdade é
o direito é outro traz energia que ele
traz de volta porque a partir do momento
em que entrou em contato com o outro e é
uma experiência que todos nós temos
temos observado o outro entre as
histórias que as pessoas nem imagina
nesse ele sofre coisa passa por momentos
da vida que nem imagina ea nossa anos e
falando muito porque ele é hora que a
pessoa possa enfim é toda a experiência
esses mais de 25 anos de carreira me
fizeram perceber que nenhuma pessoa
prevista em lei
nenhum e falou com muita convicção não
valeu a pena
nenhum porque embora é óbvio que
perpassa ressalta
tem pessoas que falam mais pessoas que
falam menos pessoas que usam mais
extrovertidas é pessoas - mas enfim eu
acredito eu acredito é que todo ser
humano tem a sua luz
essa história tem o seu poder tenha sua
capacidade de transformação mas na
maioria das vezes esses irmão não achou
ainda é não se achou mundo não por sua
presença não reviu seus conceitos não se
diz carol
isso pra professor então estamos falando
aqui de seres humanos e tudo começa aqui
dentro na nossa cabeça e no coração
inter visando essas pessoas é eu aprendi
muito na vida do homem de hoje com os
nossos colegas nos conceitos dicas e
histórias inspiradoras é isso que a
gente vai falar mulher incrível
é um livro que surgiu depois de um
problema um programa que eu trabalhei
durante dois anos é que eu comecei a ver
essa mudança
menina eu lanço 1971 é de uma mulher
extremamente especial que tomou conta de
mim me sozinho praticamente então nos
anos 70
não era fácil você trabalhar e tomar
conta não era fácil
o terceiro é o divórcio não existia ip
eram tantos os desafios e problemas
questionamentos para nove mulheres e um
em crescendo nessa toada dos 70 80 90 e
vendo essa transformação e verde para
hoje era mesmo um pouco de preconceito e
se falam já caiu na análise entre o
enquadramento de nino e aí num evento é
carreira até hoje sei
em breve começa a escutar histórias de
mulheres teve uma viagem
apaixonado 12 mulheres eu viajo durante
quatro meses
deixei minha filha meu ex-marido enfim
fui fazer com que o filho ia viajar pelo
mundo e conhecer mulheres de todas as
modalidades que tivessem tempo
realidades fizessem alguma coisa que a
gente faz a nossa é em uma ação local
mas força normal e que pode gerar zinho
ações normais porque a condição é ou
ativistas ou o odf longe de inovadores
projectos inovadores e que criar de novo
sapiro o desafio inventado
vou falar os países que eu passei essa
viagem foi 2009 áfrica do sul vietnã
tailândia e nos finlândia olhar uma meta
petal lituânia frança holanda aí depois
eu fui pro meu peru méxico cidadania vez
que voltei para o brasil
vou apresentar a vocês a história da
mulher que é o senhor ei no livro tem 50
mulheres e no programa foram 144 12 em
cada bairro e 12 para o valor do amor
o valor da solidariedade qual a história
dela
bastante porque é ela estaria com star
wars bastante para bonito e muito mais
desse conceito do que ela voltou ela
cresceu é uma modificação em uma família
pobre não tivesse média durante a copa a
parte difícil conseguir isso básico a
médica se tornou especialista em saúde
pública e trabalhar em hospitais
públicos e tinha muitos a idéias como
vocês a acessar pela novidade da áfrica
do sul
os milhões e milhões de adeptos que
existem lá cruzo e aí ela começou a ver
e juntamente a esses pacientes vinham
jeito porque crianças presas de 45 anos
que ficam nos corredores e quando os
pais morreu essas crianças eram uma
franja moduladas ótimos médicos que
estão aqui cuidando aqui e eu vou cuidar
da nova geração
a idéia é tico sou não vamos coordenar a
formação das crianças e ela olhou com a
instituição chamada aqui mãe ela curta
três locais de várias crianças hoje
a mais velha e idéia é aumentado
é mais uma ação local com equipe de uma
necessidade médica e foi fazendo um
trabalho especial
agora vou falar pra vocês na história da
finlandesa deixando o carro também coisa
bastante ela inglesa
nasceu numa fazenda sempre aprendeu em
casa tudo sobre a sustentabilidade tem
palestra história de sustentabilidade
que hoje é todo mundo meio que sabe mas
até anos atrás não era assim quando está
entrevistei ii a imóveis limite não era
mesmo então eu vejo uma certa evolução
mas o que essa mulher fez foi muito
especial é ó trabalhava numa fábrica de
tecidos ela estilista e viu como a sogra
era um quitute levadas quanto
desperdício existia uma vez a ideia de
e ou a globo enquanto dias seriam estas
de esperança global exatamente o tema tá
falando aqui voltar pra vocês
a equipe de zé programa internet
deslocou um acerto muito legal acho
abril em outros países
materiais como borracha de veículos
automotivos quando de publicidade onde
foi o solitário
aqui estão acompanhando esse lado olha
aí nada de ilícito a gente já falou isso
de roupa carol a primeira palestrante
falou muito do desperdício para aplicar
já tinha feito de forma de trabalho
aliadas mala de viagem com ele porque tá
bonito tem ter perguntado se esperava
porque é esse quadro tem que ter um
desejo teve terá que resolver
olha a boca é coberto de lona é uma
iniciativa maravilhosa mas eu acho e
cada uma personalidade o seu poder a sua
luz o seu foco e têm que achar a outra é
fazer o que eu quero fazer por vir
e aí vai ampliando o conceito do local
que o vídeo que o vídeo falou à moda do
país do bairro local e vai aprender
nunca foi tão fácil ser conectado à
tóquio
enfim
ido até quisesse formado bom vamos para
a história a terceira mulher a maria
villar espuma perozo mecânica começou a
aprender o ofício ainda adolescente
sofreu muito preconceito
acredito num carro ainda hoje
lá ela começou a minha chegada que é o
de hoje é o seguinte você geram o efeito
em você que fai é aproximar o outro
muitas vezes você verdadeira e aí você
pode ver o que que você pode fazer com
aquela sua habilidade e talento para a
sua casa
vinho a família do seu bairro a sua
qualidade à sociedade o seu país
tudo com nossa força interior
a nossa inspiração e hoje nem se tudo
que vocês estão fazendo aqui é ter essa
esperança não conhecer histórias
interior e motivar as pessoas cada vez
mais porque a gente tem que pensar no
normal mesmo não vai funcionar num
grande negócio
[Música]
eu acredito na unidade em outro dia
o movimento todo que vai transformar o
mundo o nosso país eu vá agora vai vai e
eu quero ajudar para finalizar as minhas
duas mulheres que vincent contou que o
tio ea mãe dona mira que eu citei aqui
minha filha clara e 12 anos na itália a
menorzinha ela é a grande inspiração ele
a grande motivação para acreditar no
amor e ea generosidade muito obrigada
por você
[Aplausos]